[MUSIC]
I think number one benefit that I
believe is the flexibility.
I always wanted to do an MBA, but
the whole commute and other things
was a little difficult for me.
And when these on demand courses
actually came when I was doing some
research, I felt like the time
commitment was short.
It fit with my schedule really
well, and I was able to learn
something new while not slowing
down on other aspects of my life.
>> The format of the course is very
hands on, it's very practical, it's
very structured, simple to apply.
>> The benefits of course that I
could think about is the framework
with which I'm thinking
about the problem, the business,
the competition.
I'm definitely seeing
myself apply whatever I learned
on a day to day basis.
>> And it was structured in such a
way that you got to apply a lot of
thinking, and that was a fun part.
>> Every participant gets their
assignments that they have to
submit, and then they get
the feedback from the facilitators.
There is some reflection with them.
I was looking for some guidance,
frameworks, thinking
support in that area so that we can
restrict our own business.
And the Stanford course enabled me
to look at it from an outsider's
point of view on my own business.
And it enabled me to identify
growth and optimization that has
been super beneficial to me even to
the leadership team of my company.
>> If you want to learn something
these individual
courses are definitely
changing the way one can operate.
I would say just don't wait,
just take it.
[MUSIC]